it seems like there have been a lot of
advancements recently and it seems at
least if I look on Twitter that the pace
of development in AI is accelerating is
that fair to say or is that just uh
we've been talking about incredible uh
it's and it's always for the last 10
years 15 years it's been accelerating
far faster than the leading people in
the in the field thought it would that
to me is the most remarkable thing um
things that we said in the book Big Data
were the things that I gave in talks 5
years later that I imagined was going to
be coming down the Pike within my
lifetime happened within 2 years 5 years
like I blinked and we had Alexa and
voice recognition I blinked again and we
had GPT and I'm suffering from more
Whiplash than anyone else because I was
there I was present at the creation in
terms of the modern variant of machine
learning and I'm stunned by the
progress